l'ensemble du québec est en zone verte
depuis ce matin ce qui signifie que de
nouveaux assouplissements entre en
vigueur les rassemblements de 20
personnes sont désormais permis à
l'extérieur des domiciles privés la même
restriction sap et s'applique pour les
bars et les restaurants avec une limite
de 20 personnes par tables à l'extérieur
par contre les boss sont encore limités
à 50% de leurs capacités et la vente
d'alcool doit cesser à minuit jusqu'à
250 personnes peuvent assister à des
funérailles ou un mariage mais seulement
25 personnes peuvent participer à une
réception si elle est à l'intérieur et
50 série à l'extérieur on pourrait
croire que tout revient à la normale
alors que le québec entier basculent en
zone verte aujourd'hui
or ce n'est pas tout à fait le cas pour
les commerçants j'en parle avec jandy
côté directeur général du conseil
québécois du commerce de détail bonjour
de ce côté bonjour ça va bien oui alors
dites-nous québec continue de
recommander qu'une seule personne par
ménage se déplace en magasin qu'on
privilégie la livraison quand c'est
possible
le nombre de personnes admises par mètre
carré n'ont pas encore changé avec les
nouvelles règles ce matin avec le
passage en zone verte
est-ce que la santé publique doit lever
toutes les restrictions qui s'appliquent
au commerce de détail selon vous est ce
qu'on observe c'est qu'il ya certaines
restrictions qui sont tout de même
accepté nécessaires comme le cas du bac
ce que où la présence de pécs et glageon
la distanciation
on reste quand même surpris que les
mesures qui restreint le nombre de
personnes dans macquarie d'aller dans
les magasins qu'ils soient toujours en
place
d'autant plus que dans d'autres
industries les mesures plus restrictives
ont été levés tôt nous aurions espéré
que de passer deux journées ouvertes
aurait permis d'adn est un peu plus de
personnes à l'intérieur du magasin et
d'éviter les files comme on le constate
depuis quelques
depuis quelques temps à la porte d'aude
de nos commerces c'est début de la
saison estivale les commerces sorte de
15 mois des pandémies comment se portent
les entreprises du commerce de détail la
distribution au québec les entreprises
tout dépend dans les secteurs les
secteurs qui vont très très bien si vous
vous êtes promenés dans 10
garneau sports au lac et qui a écrit
vous êtes qu observer quand même qu' il
ya des gens qui les fréquentent et des
ventes se font dans d'autres secteurs
qui ont subi un peu plus de conséquences
on le sait quand la mode entre hautes
ourmes c'est un peu plus difficile où la
reprise commence à paraître
mais les prochains mois seront
déterminants lors en termes de reprise
qu'elle sera là la force de cette
reprise dans certains secteurs donc
c'est pas étable à tout le monde le
commerçant de détails la reprise n'est
pas égal tous les suspects a donc à quoi
on nous verrons dans les prochains mois
qu'est ce que quelqu'un s'en sortir
mieux que d'autres
elle n'est peut-être pas égales non plus
en termes de taille d'entreprise la fci
a lancé son concours je choisis pme
parce que la majorité des consommateurs
canadiens ont privilégié des grandes
surfaces au détriment des commerces
locaux
est-ce que vous c'est un phénomène qui
vous inquiète mais clairement il ya de
la place pour tout le monde donc on
pille on réitère souvent dans nos
propres communication c'est à dire
l'achat local est important le commerce
de proximité
il y aura un changement de comportement
commerce de détail qui sera conséquence
de prandelli les gens ont eu une baisse
d'habitude donc on espère que le
commerce de proximité va reprendre un
peu plus de vigueur les grandes surfaces
qui s'en sort très bien qu'ils sont
québécoises donc les grandes surfaces
aussi qui ont profité de cette manne de
clientèle et le commerce électronique
mais ce qu'on perçoit ce qui aura des
espaces un peu pour tout le monde dans
la motrice dépendamment de du modèle
qu'on va privilégier parce qu'ils
répondent à des besoins moyens
différents de chaque cliente parlant de
moder on a beaucoup parlé de
piétonisation des artères commerciales
depuis début la pandémie ça fait pas
toujours consensus auprès des
propriétaires
est ce que vraiment ça fait une
différence permet la circulation est ce
que ça n ous a nui aux marchands selon
vous qu'est ce que vous sentez chez vos
membres
mais il ya deux écoles le bas vous
l'avez dit l école de les gens qui ont
peu plus de difficulté il ya une école
ou six qui dit que la petite
organisation aime énormément de trafic
lorsqu'on pose la question lorsqu'on
fait des sondages on pose la question
aux gens est-ce que vous privilégiez la
pluie piétonnisation pas 66 % des gens
nous répondre que oui
donc il ya clientèle
et en faveur de la piétonnisation d'un
commerce de talent clientèle et rennes
donc on espère que non commerçants y
répondre il ya aussi l'aspect trafic
piétonnier donc se promener
tranquillement devant une vitrine permet
d'observer le commerce de détail de
façon plus approfondie que de rouler
devant donc mais la piétonnisation ça
dépend aussi des rues des rues la
configuration qu'on privilégie est
certaine évolution plus accessible que
d'euros il faut pas non plus
nécessairement empêché la livraison ou
le stationnement pour les commerces de
destination
l'autre chose dont on a beaucoup discuté
c'est le magasinage en ligne de nombreux
québécois ont pris l'habitude de
magasiner en ligne durant le confinement
quel point est ce que vous attendez à ce
que ce soit une tendance qui reste au
cours des prochains mois prochain johnny
c'était une tendance qui était déjà là
avant donc ça ne sème la part des miens
axel est restée la tendance certains me
disent qu'ils ont fait 5 ans
d'accélération de commerce en ligne
si vous promener dans les rues
résidentielles de percevoir les camions
de livraisons sont monnaie courante
donc il y aura dès qu'il y aura quand
même des habitudes qui ont été créées
qui vont rester
cependant on constate dans les derniers
mois que lorsqu'on pose la question ce
que les rétentions de continuer à
augmenter la consommation avec des gens
ne répondent que plus ou moins donc il y
aura peut-être une stabilisation des
proportions actuelles de consommation en
ligne au niveau qu'on constate
actuellement donc pour pour l'avenir
peut-être plus habitué à léo pourcentage
ou encore sur le post merci beaucoup à
ce côté très intéressant tout ça on va
suivre évidemment les développements
pour les commerçants en cours des
prochaines semaines pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
oh